All right, for those that you are new, I see there are some new faces on here.
Understand everybody is muted, so we chat questions in, use your chat.
If you have questions that you weren't able to get in from the member site, the best way to get questions in is you ask them on the member site.
And just about every one of the pages, you can ask a question, ask a Zoom call question mocks is on that site.
But sometimes things come pop into your mind as we're going through this, so that's a good time to ask a question.
So feel free to chat that in.
We usually spend about an hour, sometimes it's less, sometimes it's more, but let's get started.
All right, and we'll get to the chat questions at the end after we get through all the other questions reminder to always go to the members site for your initial announcements, any changes, any updates, anything.
I'll put it on the member site on the homepage.
So this is from the homepage from just a little bit ago.
And there's a couple of doubts that's the binder Zoom calls don't think it pertains to anybody on the call today are going to be one on one for the next few weeks.
Everybody has access to the courses, I've said that already.
And we talked about the PDF from Dr. McCola about the recipe for devilizing hydrogen peroxide.
There's a question later, so we'll discuss that.
And this is something a little bit new right here.
We need to ask everyone to please only ask questions via the member site.
Well, I just discussed the little box saying ask your Zoom call questions here. Of course, you can chat a bit of this on the Zoom call.
But I'm talking about as opposed to emailing questions.
There are some legal issues with emailing answers.
So we need to, so I hope nobody's offended if you forget any email a question in because you're going to get an answer that says please.
We'll answer this on the Zoom call.
We have to do that. There's just some.
Just we just have to stay safe in everything that you do.
Here's the courses. If you go on the courses page on the website, the different courses that you have access to.
That could be very helpful for you.
Number one, the right ball. Just want to confirm you leave it in the plastic tube. If you don't take it out.
Yes, don't take it out of the plastic tube. Absolutely.
Don't you avoid the warranty and you'll be writing a new ball. So do not take it out of the plastic tube.
Yes, correct. Please go to the member site. Look on the right page.
You see a whole bunch of the right questions answered on there too. So make sure you're utilizing the member site that best you possibly can.
My oncologist suggested that I increase my B vitamins to help build back my red blood cells following chemo last year. I also take B liver capsules.
I take one, rather than the suggested one, and also has B vitamins. For a few months, I took extra B's. Your encapsulation be complex.
I opened the capsules and took one half or one third of them. My latest lab did not show any improvement.
Excuse me. My latest lab did show some improvement.
The last week's Zoom call you mentioned that cancer patients don't need too many methyl groups. Hopefully I got that right. Yes, you did.
If I am in remission, does that still apply? Would you suggest taking an extra B complex or not?
Yes, I said if you're in remissioned and you're dealing with low hemoglobin or
especially if you're dealing with high homocysteine levels. So homocysteine is a product of the misdiadiene cycle and homocysteine is a metabolic midpoint metabolite, meaning that it isn't necessarily it's kind of a bad guy.
It's too high of concentrations in our body. It's not supposed to stay into high concentrations because it's supposed to be converted to downstream metabolite that is less dangerous and it's dependent upon some B vitamins and folate in order for it to convert.
That is deficient in folate and some of the B vitamins could have high homocysteine and that's the most dangerous thing for heart disease.
So if your homocysteine is high, then you do need to take more B's and you can even take some methyl-bethylated B's for that sake.
Certainly, if you're in remission, you don't really need this doesn't necessarily apply to you, even if you don't apply homocysteine, you can still certainly take methyl-bethylate.
Do you have anti-eoplastic therapy at Futter's clinic? No, that's only available through Dr. Brazinski in Houston, Texas.
Would that be an intelligent choice for stage 4 breast cancer metastasized brain lungs and liver? You'd have to consult with them. I've got a specialist in that, that's his, what he does.
Do you provide thermo-ablation of colors? No, we don't provide any invasive therapies like that.
I've noticed that my foot bath water color has turned from a caramel brown to a much darker gray black color.
It has been this color ever since I got my new foot bath machine. Does this have anything to do with a rise in my CA 19 numbers? If not, what does it mean?
So the colors in your foot bath, I have a video about that that I don't put a lot of credence on the colors that you might Google and say, oh, this means it's coming from my liver or this means it's coming from this or whatever.
I don't put a lot of credence on that. The only time you want to really be concerned with the color is the lack thereof. You have no discoloration change.
When you do your foot bath, then you have to question whether you need to replace your eye up the way it should not have anything to do with the rise of your CA 19 numbers.
So the darker color is just fine. You want it a darker color. It could be a caramel brown to a darker color. If it's just clear after you do your foot bath, then you need to replace your eye up the way.
I've been reading the book how to starve your cancer and I've only gotten halfway through. Do you agree with what she's success, what she's reporting with the book in terms of all the drugs and protocols she suggests?
This is Jade McClellan's book. With my recent rise and two of our friends, I'm getting nervous all over and continue to look for answers. So yes, a lot of birthdays. We have some of our members that are using some of the protocols that all of them.
Some of them make sense. So you can go through Google care oncology. That's who all of our other members are going through to use those protocols and you can pick and choose what you want to do.
Some of them seem to be for different cancer seem to be seem to make a little bit less sense, but some of them can make a lot of sense of that can be another approach that you can take.
There's no change in what we would do. You would do it to nutritional approach. You could just add those to your approach as well.
My primary diet is juicy. Is it normal to share girly in my stomach all day? Or is this indicated something I need to be aware of?
So girly in your stomach all day can be due to a need for hydrochloric acid and digestive enzymes.
So it might be good to take some HCL sign HCL-XYM is the product I'm talking about. It's HCL hydrochloric acid, which is needed in your stomach and digestive enzymes, which is needed in your stomach and your first part of your intestines.
You see, though it's pre-digesting things, it's breaking it down into smaller particles. It's still raw and raw food is difficult to digest and it can cause some girly in your intestinal tract.
So if the girly is more of your intestinal tract than digestive enzymes, that would be the thing that you would help support that.
And understand, girly in your stomach doesn't mean it's a problem. It doesn't mean it's an issue at all. It's not necessarily an indication of really anything.
So unless you're having some other digestive issues, I don't know that I would even, you know, think that you need to hold on and take a bunch of different stuff.
I would continue on your point.
With ultraviolet blood irradiation therapy, be useful in preventing the gastricists or other anti-cancer benefits, if so, is this procedure that is usually prescribed by MDs?
No, it's not usually prescribed by any oncologists. It's more of an alternative therapy.
And I personally don't know any clinics in the Midwest that do this therapy.
Yeah, you'd have to look around and do it. Is it beneficial? That can be. I mean, there can be benefit to it.
But again, you're radiating the blood or your ozoneating the blood.
You're just taking it out. You have a portal in one arm and another in another and it splits your machine and it's going right through your body like that.
That's how that machine works.
To me, that makes more sense for pathogen therapy, like life disease and things that it does so for cancer.
But I know that there are the doctors that do have the machines are doing it for cancer too.
So you'll have to look into that. I don't do that.
Are there any concerns about doing too much of a good thing? I currently use rightly right machine.
The true right by input. So six days per week.
The fever, P E M F, eight minutes twice a day, supplements, jump on a midi trip, walk 30 minutes a day, diet is okay, but couldn't prove.
I don't see any of those of me too much.
Maybe you certainly if you're doing well, what would I cut out this this protocol right here first, I would probably cut that I am grow waves down.
If you're not doing well, if you're doing poorly, I would continue this protocol, but if you're doing really well, I would cut out that thing that takes this much the most time that is.
I would cut out by and throw away the walkie the exercise course takes time, but that's something you really need to keep going so.
Here my blood results taken yesterday, not what I wanted to see any suggestions from here one question does detox using supplements food right.
I am throwing Castro packs, etc, increase the numbers six months, all from kingdom.
So I did write down this person's blood work, what was elevated the AST, the alkaline phosphatase in the CVA.
But I did notice that we didn't have any data on past numbers for this person.
So I can't make a comparison, so I'm assuming that this person is saying that these were elevated prior to this test or they're at a higher level than they were six months ago.
But let's talk about that elevated AST indicates liver issues, but it's not specific.
It's not a specific test like, oh, you have fatty liver disease, it just elevates elevated AST is a liver enzyme and that will be elevated if you have liver congestion.
Could it be the test is in the liver, would can be elevated with the test is delivered, but a lot of people have AST elevations and no, the test is delivered and they don't even have cancer has nothing to do with cancer in its raw form, it could be completely independent.
C.E.A. is a tumor marker, so if C.E.A. is elevated from prior, then that's a concern because that's an elevated tumor marker. So if your two are who goes up, again, you don't take one test by itself, you measure it with other signs and symptoms and other objective findings.
So if your seat, let's say you did a CT scan and the tumor shrunk, but the C.E.A. it went up in a PET scan and there's no new signs of any metastasis, but the C.E.A. went up, well then you might just ignore that C.E.A. test in a sense, you put it in the back pocket and you might look at other objective tests.
Yet I don't have baseline on where the C.E.A. was and if you don't have a baseline of the C.E.A. and it's elevated about normal, you have no idea what it was before, maybe it was much higher.
So you compare the data of a test to the previous test was my first one.
Okay, well, then it just you already know you have cancer. So it's very common to have it elevated to a marker like C.E.A. which is fairly broad to a marker.
If you have cancer, so if you don't have anything to compare it to it's, you know, to be a point that we got to baseline. So,
it can be elevated if there's, if there's congestion in the liver, if there's toxicity in the liver, if there's metastasis in the liver, but a common reason why alkaline phosphatase is elevated with people that have a previous cancer diagnosis is,
is metastasis to bone. So your oncologist should be looking for that. If you see alkaline phosphatase be elevated with a patient that has a diagnosis of cancer, you should be looking at bone.
So, how do you look at bone, you can do a PET scan, you do a CT scan if the person has CT scans are regional. So the issue with that is, you know, the whole body regional CT scans.
So then you limit your CT scan. If the person had, let's say, they had screaming low back pain, you do a CT scan, it's better scan to visualize the bone in MRI. So you do a CT scan of the one bar spider, the low back or the lower abdominal area.
And you'd make sure that there is an any body metastasis, because if there is lytic metastasis, meaning that bone is being eroded away, which is the most common type of body metastasis for any type of cancer is an elytic metastasis, not a plastic metastasis, which is laid out of bone. So you got a body erosion.
It gives off and elevates your alkaline phosphatase.
So, not to concern you, but you got to be a realist, you got to go, okay, but I'll elevate the alkaline phosphatase, your, your oncologist should be going, we need to be located and make sure that there's no body metastasis.
And then if there is, if you do find body metastasis and then you're working at treated it, then you will, and if you're successful at it, you will see, um, you will see the alkaline phosphatase, but I actually had a console with somebody the other day that that was exactly the case.
The alkaline phosphatase dropped back down to normal, so it's great.
I started in the past couple of weeks with right-sided heaviness, who doesn't have the same flavor.
Um, well, I'm not fully understanding this question, so make sure, as best you guys possibly can, is to word your questions in a way.
But I can, that I can, um, your turbo, what you're really talking about.
Right-sided heaviness, I'm talking, I think you're talking about abdominal heaviness after eating, if you're talking about food.
Um, in, you really want to make sure you're not constipated, um, make sure you're after your balls every day.
Food doesn't have the same flavor is, is, is, is very different.
So the taste of food, um, might be related to viral infection.
It's very common, you have a bad cold or some sort of viral infection that you could lose your sense of taste.
Um, especially if it's some sort of respiratory infection or if it's in your cytosis.
So, um, I think that's the best I could answer that question.
Question with Dr. McCullough's formula for lung infection, how many times a day we think I should debulence.
So this person is talking about this thing, I put the PDF of Dr. McCullough the recipe for us.
Nebulized hydrogen peroxide to help heal the lungs because the last few Zoom calls we had questions about issues with lungs, respiratory issues,
uh, fungal infections in the lungs, et cetera.
Nebulized hydrogen peroxide.
And debulizing other things is to be very beneficial.
You could debulize below the silver.
You could put a drop of essential oil in with the hydrogen peroxide or colloidal silver.
Um, that's again, you're getting, um, whatever you're trying to do.
Hydro peroxide is a great topical antiseptic. Why?
Because H2O2 is hydrogen peroxide and it can easily give up an oxygen free radical.
Um, that can be a danger of consuming the hydrogen peroxide orally because oxygen free radicals are free or oxygen radical species that can damage cells that actually be a cause of cancer.
But in, uh, at a topical setting, it actually kills bacteria because it'll attach to bacteria viruses and fungus and kill them.
So it's a, that's what makes it a great antiseptic.
So, um, when you're debulizing, it's a great antiseptic for things in your lung.
Now, if I just have really weak lungs and it has nothing to do with fungus, if it has nothing to do with any type of bacterial infection or viral infection.
But maybe it's asthma or maybe it's an allergy that hydrogen peroxide would not be the thing that I would fabulous.
Um, you, you know, I had your prox and if you think it's some sort of pathogen, some sort of infection, which is very common with cancer.
So that's why we talked about that.
But if it's allergies and it's an histamine issue and a mass cell issue, I wouldn't be debulizing your hydrogen peroxide.
So there's other choices, but that's not what we're talking about.
How many times a day you can use, you can do this four or five times a day and tell you feel better.
Um, my wife does this a lot because she has, um, made your issues with her lungs from when she was a child and put on medications.
Her parents were not naturally lighted and all.
And, um, this, I tell you, the regularizing hydro peroxide and other things helps her the more than anything.
So, um, good choices.
I've been listening to a lot of your live recordings.
And I'm wondering if you can explain a bit more.
I have a live though under my right arm that they biopsy it and showed cancer.
By the end of the day, sometimes it is very sore and large, but goes down overnight.
This last week, it started on the left side.
Um, I understand that they are our bodies car wash.
At what point, um, do they start to clear up or swelling will down.
Well, your lip nodes will increase in size if there's an infection.
Um, if you have blockage in the lip, though, because you have some cancer growing in the lip, don't, then it will increase in size at different times simply because, um,
blue and goes through there. So remember, your live system is like an open ended capillary system. It isn't open ended capillary system.
And I like it to have several videos on the live system on the member side.
So do look at those, but it's like, um, your storm sewers in your street.
Well, if your street floods, you have 10 inches of rain overnight and water has to go somewhere and it's rising down to the storm sewers.
Well, if you have blockage in that sewer.
Um, in the, in the street, it's going to back up.
And that's what could happen if you have tumor cells in the lip, though, and then it's going to, you're going to notice the swelling, you're going to lose swelling around that lip, though, you're going to notice some lack of drainage.
But normally if there's a formal rain storm, they will back, you know, sewers can back up because of that.
And that's where, like, if you have a horrible infection, your lip builds can get larger.
And then they will go back down. That's called build hypertrophy.
Um, and then they do go back down. You probably notice this with your children. If you have kids, they get it really sick or something and they have.
Um, swollen the bones. Well, they're really small.
They're had hypertrophy to try to kill an infection.
So, and then they will go back down.
So when we live notes themselves are where the drainage tube of whatever area is being drained, goes through and it's a conglomeration of different blood cells to be able to kill anything because it drains back into the blood system.
And we certainly don't just want the extra cellular spaces, the spaces around yourselves, the fluid to go into the storm sewers.
Then we're going to put it back in the bloodstream. Normally your storm sewers are going to.
That's like putting your storm sewers down in the river. You're just polluting the river. Well, that wasn't a good idea when they decided to do that a hundred years ago, so they're changing those things.
Um, well, our storm sewers are going right back into our river of our bloodstream. But they have a filtration system which kills any pathogens.
Um, called your lymph nodes. So that's what your lymph nodes do. They filter this out. So it kills any pathogens.
Um, so you're not actually causing a systemic infection.
What do you recommend for pain management to answer your joint pain? Well, Coleman, I'm sure I have a using clear in plan. I take three to four capsules three to four times a day.
Is there something else that will work? So you are taking really the right dosage of that. So clear in plan is a lot of the flavonoids.
Uh, curcumin, as well as baritone, tea extract.
I think I, I remember correctly.
I think sticky metal is in there.
There is a product called.
It's an evolved product called limitless evolve limitless. That could help that's a betalent.
Uh, and it's a patented process where they take betalent, which is an enzyme for the liver.
That is the extremely anti-inflammatory enzyme that can really help with pain.
There's a lot of testimonials, uh, limitless. So limitless comes in a box. The capsules are sealed and, um, just take a couple of those a day.
Limitless by, um, Halloween.
Would you recommend that all cancer patients take these ever teen? No. Or would their genetics indicate no.
The protocol is not recommended to be by you, but I have recently begun to take, um, African Power B 17, um, in a protocol that works up to a high doses.
I have a fun gating tumors. I have fun day tumors. Is there any, um, information available that shows that B 17 will be beneficial to reduce or healing these tumors or the rules they create.
Um, I don't, you know, it's gonna be really hard. You have to use duck or something to search for, um, resources on, um, B 17, um, because that's lay a trail and lay a trail is something that has been just shut down by Google.
So I do have information on that website, but I don't have anything specific on what you're talking about there. So, um, what to use a multiple search engine to search for.
I'm missing eating chips. Is it okay for me to eat, see at day, grain free tortilla chips. Yeah, I'm familiar with them. Yes, you could eat them. Can you eat the whole bag? Sure.
That's the rule sitting. Can I use ozone far infrared every day? Um, yes, I would say.
Yeah. Is large, okay, to use as fat.
Uh, yes, yep. I would say yes.
Uh, just got my genetic test results in today. Can you do a phone conference versus watching the video to go over it?
Um, no, we can't. We get on the genetic Q and A Thursday.
Um, and we can go over a few things with it. Oh, no, we can't. I can't do it this Thursday, the next Thursday. So next Thursday, the genetic Q and A is when we could go over it.
Um, that would be the most appropriate way to do this.
Um, I think I did a, no, no, it opened a coconut charcoal pill to rinse my mouth and I accidentally inhaled some charcoal.
Can I clear that out of my lungs? I am very worried.
Um, I don't think there's 80 harm in that. I don't think that you're going to worry about that. If you, you absorb any of that through the alveolar spaces, there's no harm in charcoal and be in your bloodstream, you don't filter that out. So I wouldn't worry about that.
Um, if you feel like something is your lungs and your coffee and stuff, you just don't want to cause infection. Hey, what do you do for that? You go back to devilized.
Sorry, I mixed the charcoal in a glass of water to be more specific. Yeah, that could happen. I know.
Um, and that's being the same thing if you, if you were reading anything, you're out in a dust storm or, you know, people that live near the desert and these, these windstorms that could cause, um, you know, red tide issues that you're living near the ocean.
You've got these fungal type things that can cause a lot of infections in the, but people don't realize you're thinking, you know, you're eating things bad. That's how it's into your system and causes problems.
Certainly injecting things is the fastest way to get a toxin in your system.
But actually the second fastest way to get toxic in your system is breathing it.
So we damage our lungs more than we think.
And so there can be little hidden infections, but in your lungs that you don't even know about.
So I have a big plan of devilized things.
You sell B vitamins that you recommend for those with cancer. Yes, we talked about that last week in the week before.
That would be the B specific naturally. So the B specific naturally is product that is.
First of all, it's, it's whole food.
The whole food B is important because synthetic bees are not the greatest things for us.
But it's also lower in the methylated products. It doesn't have methyl B12 in it, but it's a lower dosage that, you know, high doses of methyl groups. You don't have the methyl groups that can silence to their suppressive genes.
Be specific naturally. It's by.
Do our cheek swabs that we said did show energetically whether cancer is still present or not?
Yeah, we can't legally say that or not. So, you know, we had just, you know, we coming, coming under more and more scrutiny by.
The, the, the power is that be they're trying to destroy us every way, shape and form. That's why we ask for your prayers.
And we can't say anymore that whether cancer's coming up or not or even energetically, you know, we got to be just so careful on anything that we were.
It's trying to destroy us. So, it's just a constant band. I had the volume is still having chest pain, but lungs are clear. Okay, so.
Stop right there.
There's Dr. Gaby and healer, but have been doing Dr. Recola's portal post at which point could be better.
Why have no idea what the handler is. Is it an antibiotic or is it some sort of just steroid to open up your one.
Spaces.
Certainly, if the person is having issues, I think, I feel like I can catch my breath. You want to take medication. So a drug that will open up those pathways.
It saved your life. You don't want to stay around with that.
But, you know, steroid type drug that's going to open up pathways is going to do anything to kill any residual infection just because you're X-ray.
But you say, I haven't had the motive of my chest and have chest pain, but my lungs are clear. That's that sounds like radiology terminology. So a radiologist will look at an X-ray and say, Oh, your lungs are clear.
Meeting in that you don't have any infection. Well, just because you can't see it on an X-ray doesn't mean you don't have any great infection. You have bacteria or viral bug.
It's a way that are still carbonated causing issues. So it's great that it's not present an X-ray, but just because that president of X-ray is not me.
First, I'm going to full blow the volume that you can't see it on the actual. So you still treat it if you're having symptoms treat the symptoms.
So which will be better? You could do both.
It's mentally blue, photo dynamics therapy. Okay, for me. Yeah, I would say yes.
Is your tomorrow clear at the same as fourth and molecular to, to, uh, to rev up. Yes, the same thing. Our tomorrow clear is there.
Is there to even that we private label they private label it for us. So they are in the way.
Real is the inhaler just doctor just listen to your lungs. Okay.
Are you familiar? It's all understand you give me a drum when you guys ask me a question. Should I take this drug or not? I can't answer the question.
So you can ask the question, but I'm going to have to say I can answer the question.
But I can help reason through things with you. Let me just talk about it. Reason these things.
Are you familiar with SCACT? Yes, yeah.
And you know, we have SCACT at our store. We have.
I have multiple articles about SCACT right about SCAC.
100 KC in my book. Great, great, terrible things.
It's the heat of infrared heating pad or any other heat. Increased blood flow.
Yes, yes, it does. Isn't that bad for cancer? No, no, well, it's not.
So you don't want. When you talk about increased blood flow of cancer, you're talking about we don't want increased growth of blood, blood vessels in the tumor.
First of all, we're not talking about any of the blood cancers here. We're not talking about multiple myeloma or any of the leukemia is talking about hard tumor.
Hard tumor is a tumor that is a mass. So we don't want to allow increase of growth of blood vessels into the tumor because that is what will bring food and feed the tumor.
So heat is not going to do that. He will increase blood flow and around the tumor, which actually can help in ways and tumors do not like heat. That's the whole idea.
Well, hyperthermia. So hyperthermia is another cancer therapy that increases the heat deep. So the heating pad is only an increase the heat like maybe, you know, or more millimeters deep, you know, in your skin.
It can, you know, cause some burden of the dermis and epidermis layers. It's not going to cause really a whole lot more like that, but it will warm up. I mean, as far as damaging will warm up other things. That's why they keep over the liver can be good.
But when this person showed me a picture of what they happened with it using a correct heat that's what I was concerned about using it overnight. You could burn yourself for the easy and not even notice it. So just be careful with it.
Oh, say I use heat overnight. Lots of times if I have like a chest cold or my back is hurting or something like that. I'll use the infrared heating pad with the little stones on it.
And I'll just make sure make sure that it's turned down. And I usually wear, you know, it's over a shirt or something between that and my body or something like that.
So because you fall asleep, you could be in a deep sleep, but you could burn yourself or you don't even know it.
So is there a new circulated sugar test within the United States that is new and our doctors can order. I thought you mentioned one few months ago.
No, so there are circulated tumor tests that I don't think you're asking the right question.
I'm not in favor of doing circulated tumor tests. There's lots of circulated tumor tests.
But to me, there's no value in measuring circulating tumor cells.
To me, there's no value at all. You're taking a blood sample and say, are there any circulated tumor cells in there? Well, what to do? What do you care? I mean, your body is your tumor is given off circulating tumor cells at some point of time.
And the ones that are circulating in your blood, if there are any, I mean, you know, that doesn't that doesn't give us any.
It doesn't help us in the cause of care. So you just have to assume you have circulated tumor cells in the tissue somewhere, somewhere.
That's why even if you get a full clean bill of cancer, you know, you still keep doing your right, but still keep doing stuff.
Because, you know, darn well that you're a realist, you're not, you know, this screaming optimist and you're not a, you're not a negative person, but you're a realist.
You're like, okay, well, I'm sure I got cancer cells somewhere, so I'm going to continue doing this stuff. So it doesn't just take off and, you know, raise a family of million kids and now we got a problem.
So, you don't, I don't think there's any value of your circulated tumor cells test. So if you're looking about your question is really about other test that can measure whether your cancer growth or not.
There is a tendency you certainly can do.
Watch that video on the neighbor side, how the way to improve it, there are two more suppressors or tumor marker test that a person can do a social positive.
And other things that you can do to measure success or not.
Can the right be used for a fib.
If a person has a fib, I don't know that there's settings, if there's a program for a fib, there's certainly heart settings on the right.
So if a person has hard issues, you can look, I don't know if there's a fib settings that have to look.
But there's other things that could be done for a fib, many times a fib, it has to do with the vitamin D deficiency.
Yeah, so assuming this isn't you.
But certainly, you've been look, look on the right for the alphabetical listings under heart, or if there is, if it was under him.
Should I use red light therapy for anything related to my phone call or just for inflammation.
Someone suggested I go to plan a fitness to use their red light pods.
Is this sufficient.
Is there any real benefit for cancer.
Light therapy that is just red light therapy and green light therapy of blue light therapy are just in a very distinct spectrum.
It can have some benefits to skin issues.
It can have some benefits for inflammation that is more surface inflammation help with some paid issues.
You're just going to try that yourself.
It's, it's certainly given a try and see, is it going to be beneficial to help heal a person's cancer?
I would say no, not at all.
Can it help with other comorbidities?
Yes, for sure.
So I think that's worth trying those better things.
Is there a supplement that could possibly see the blood?
Yeah, there's supplements that can do the blood.
That's you do have to be careful on it.
If you're out of blood thinner, then you do have to be careful with supplements that could do the blood too much of you end up with bruising and stuff like that.
Your number one blood city supplement is garlic by far.
So years ago I've had, I have had, you know, a lot of heart patients, I actually have on the blogs multiple.
Blog posts about cardiovascular health that effect we're going to of course, and cardiovascular health probably will be done to after the first year.
But garlic is, you know, is your number one blood city nutrient.
There are some plugged in benefits with fish oils on the garlic as far as the carrier.
Again, with just like with anything else here, you know, you don't just want to treat the symptom.
You want to treat the cause with cardiovascular, especially there's a lot of your lighting caused cardiovascular disorders.
And most the time it has to do with either a toxin or a biotoxin that gets under the layer of the epithelium.
The epithelial layer of the blood vessels is called endothelial cells.
You can have a toxin or a biotoxin get under the endothelial cell and affect the different receptors in the smooth muscles.
That wrap around the vessels that function to increase or decrease blood pressure.
Why would we want to increase blood pressure? You have to increase blood pressure or you even stand from a sitting position.
Your blood pressure has to go up about 10 to 20 points or you will pass out.
You have to be able to shut blood to your brain instantaneously.
That's a hormonal reaction has to be partly with the neurological sympathetic system as well, but mainly hormonal.
And so there's a lot of different things that could block the different receptors you've heard of like ACE2 drugs.
Those are blocking ACE2 receptors.
Well, great tea extract is one of the most potent beneficial ACE2 receptor antagonists that could be really beneficial for a person.
So it's very trial, there's just a plethora of different things.
I do write about a lot of that on the blog posts that I have on currently asking.
Does the clinic still order labs as mentioned in the how do I know if I'm making progress video?
Yes, it don't. So again, we are just under a lot of scrutiny. So we have to just be careful on what we do to stay the Minnesota, but we're not going to so it anymore.
But it's so we'd rather have you get labs through your local functional medicine practitioner.
That would be safer for us.
So we ask that you try to find something local that you can order those labs. We can certainly guide you what labs you should afford.
But kind of easy because all you have to do and go on our website and go to the blog post on two markers.
And depending on what cancer you have, then you pick those two of our contestants. So they're fairly inexpensive to run to work the test. So there can be valuable to run.
And even at that, if you do have an oncologist are still working with, I would ask them first, because if you have insurance that will be covered under your insurance, they are standard medical tests.
The tests that we do run and we can run from medical legal standpointer functional medicine tests. So Syracs tests, food panel tests, and anybody tests, things like that.
So as always in the car, well, running.
We can run other tests, but we'd really rather have you get like two of our test done locally.
And you can get the color by insurance. I mean, you're sure it's what covered our test stuff.
But all you got to do is look at that blog on two markers. And you know, pretty easy to figure out what to run for test to run.
Okay, so if you have breast cancer, you know, just writing their most breast cancers will show positive to the markers. So then you can use it as an indicator.
But if you have a cancer like melanoma, you can show any two markers. So, you know, you can't do any of those lines.
So if you have, you know, make granite cancer, you're C-A-D-I-T died will show and you can use that one most likely.
Yeah, if you have a polling cancer or rectal cancer, got a little cancer.
C-D-A might be positive, the C-A-125 right now.
So you can run those inexpensive tests to see if they show if they're all with the normal range that you can't even really use any of them.
That's not when we can have a stage for patient that they don't show any to the markers. So it's kind of like, oh, what's up there?
Well, at least you can use it as a marker.
You can use it as a marker, whether you're getting better or better.
I just got my vitamin D level back and it is 81.7. Is this high enough for your useful.
Well, that's a good range, you know, you really want, I mean, I think the medical range depends on the lab that's ready to the normal is like 30 to 16, depends on the lab that's ready to.
30 to 80 some other labs, I really want my patients to be like, you know, 70 80 to 150.
So if you're taking vitamin D, I keep taking vitamin D, your medical doctor Michael, oh my gosh, 81, you need to stop taking vitamin D while we say, okay, thank you and just keep taking vitamin D.
I never got to a marker test, just CTs, MRIs, et cetera. Is there any use it even now that I've started my program?
Yeah, the reason why oncologists typically don't run tumor marker tests is there they're coming from the perspective that you are going to do what they're asking them to do.
So they're asking you to do people therapy usually.
And the negative about running to a marker test is two markers can spike if you're doing two people therapy and then patients freak out so your, you know, your CA 1999 with, with breast cancer, especially, let's say you're seeing 15 three with breast cancer.
When it was high at normal at 45, you start to keep them there, but it jumps up to 150.
And the patient freaks out and the doctor's got to talk them on the roof because tell them that it's normal for it to spike during chemotherapy.
Well, oncologists got to the point out, what are they starting to do in tests? Because I don't want to explain that to people.
So they just stop most oncologists stop running to work the test you have to ask for.
So I don't suggest doing to work the test if you're going to do chemotherapy because they're excused the test.
But if you're not doing chemotherapy and you want a not invasive way to test for progress or lack there.
You can get a true work test. So again, look at our website, search the website for to the marker and you'll see the blog.
It has to work for tests. There's about five of them that should be run for breast cancer because you don't know which one will be elevated.
Maybe all of them, maybe only one of them. So that's the thing to do with breast cancer. So breast cancers.
Most common reason why you use two.
Should by swamp test also have a review of my right frequencies after.
And increase in markers.
Can we can do that? We can look at that with your type of cancer and with anybody's cancer, it may or may not show that we're going to change your frequencies.
So just know if you don't get a flash drive, maybe we didn't change your frequencies.
So a doctor, Christy Funk says they're okay because of phyto estrogen, but I could be wrong.
So I am not a fan of soy at all, especially if you have any cancer that could be remotely influenced by hormones.
Now, if so, if you're talking about soy eating, soy eating tofu having something with soy in it, that's what I mean by a lot of things.
If you're taking a specific phyto estrogen to balance your estrogens and let's say you're in total remission.
And now you're having these horrible shock flashes, you know, being careful and gentle with that. I don't think there's a problem. I think that's probably what doctor Christy is talking about.
The phyto estrogen that is, that is removed from the soy in a specific product, typically you'd see those in nutritional products that are meant for women going through.
Menopause, so if you are in active cancer, I would probably shy away from those.
Sometimes we've given those to women, if they tested fine, but most the time they do that.
You're talking about eating soy, I would totally shy away from that. It's very hard to fight any organic non-geomal soy.
Soy is very much an estrogen stimulator.
And there's just a lot, it's a lot of ad players in soy.
Us, it's almost all the soy that you get into the United States is GMO. And that is a huge issue right there. So I would stay away from soy if I were you.
Okay, I think I have lost my voice for tonight. So just a reminder, if you jump down late, please address all your questions through the member site and not emails to Anne or Ashley or myself. I'm not trying to be mean, but I got to stop answering.
It does more than answering myself or Anne.
We got to stop answering those emails for just medical legal reasons. We have to keep it to a group.
Educational forward like this, we can be safe doing what we're doing right now. This is exactly how we want to be answering questions.
So get specific on your questions that would be the next point. I should put that in what's new here. Please get specific on your questions.
So we can understand them and try to guess what you're really talking about.
So, and then I keep people's names off the questions. And by doing that, I don't remember who asked the question.
So you might want to put in there, like many people do, you know, they say something, they say, I have breast cancer or something. So,
like, I think this person said we're paying credit and cancer. So that helps answer the question. It was different answers. The question is going to be answered different.
So thanks again for all you do. Keep praying for Anne and her son, AJ, if you haven't heard her 19 year old son was diagnosed with acute myeloid leukemia.
We started chemo two weeks ago.
He's at a point where his white blood cells like down to nothing. Still in the hospital.
Not a happy camper, 18 year old, lots to go home. And, but boy, he was just awfully sick. So we prayed for him. He has a bone marrow biopsy tomorrow morning at nine o'clock.
I told him that I just asked everybody to be prayed for him tomorrow morning that that biopsy comes out good.
So, appreciate all the prayers. All right, thank you guys again. I'll be praying for you know that I love you and I pray for you guys every day. And I ask that you just keep praying for us to appreciate all you do.
Talk to you on Monday.